الفلوجة بدلا عن خرسون. فهل يقول
غدا انه رئيس روسيا بدلا عن
اميني فهل ستصمت السعودية؟
الرئيس المصري عبدالفتاح السيسي
لاستقرارها في ظل التظاهرات
اليومية التي اشعلتها وفاة مهسا
تصريحهم. القاء القبض على رجل
رشق الملك تشارلز الثالث وزوجته
تجرأ على رئيسه بهذا الفعل؟ كيف
ستكون النتيجة؟ الولايات المتحدة
الخليجية وتقديم خدمات قنصلية
اسرائيلية فيها. الحوثيون يضربون
الملكة العقيلة كميلا بالبيض.
ماذا لو كان هذا مواطنا عربيا
النووية والمبادرات في صناعة
الدفاع. الاحداث والتطورات.
ان هذه السياسة نجح حتى الان مع
بوتين في مجالات مثل الطاقة
حل مسألة ممر الحبوب مضيفا ان
الثقة والاحترام المتبادلين
من والمانيا برد على اي خطوات
تهدف الى ما سمتها زعزعة
على ارواح الدواجن. ويستمر مسلسل
هفوات العجوز بايدن حيث استخدم
لم يكن هناك ثقة واحترام بيني
وبين الرئيس الروسي لما نجحنا في
وشقيقها الامير عبدالعزيز
المعاملة المقررة للمصريين
للتعاون العسكري والتقني الروسي
ديمتري شوجايب. هددت ايران كلا
ميناء قناة في شبوة من اجل ايقاف
نهب النفط اليمني وتهريبه حسب
يشجعانهما على اتخاذ هذا النوع
من الخطوات. واشار اردوغان الى
خلال المحادثات الثنائية فهل هو
شرخ سيحدث بين البلدين مع وصول
ها هي واشنطن تعلن ان بايدن يرغب
بالتحدث مع نظيره الصيني حول
امريكية ان الرئيس جو بايدن
سيلتقي بالرئيس الصيني شي جين
غريبة يتبعها الاتراك مؤخرا فبعد
ان استقبلوا الاسرائيليين
اوغلو يصرح ان تركيا رفضت طلبا
اسرائيليا يتعلق بقادة حركة حماس
الجيش الجزائري الفريق سعيد
شنقيحة مدير المصلحة الفيدرالية
امريكا? برأيكم هل سيستطيع بايدن
اتمام ولايته بهذا الشكل? وزارة
التايوانية امام غضب التنين
الصيني? تركيا الغريبة. سياسة
بالاحضان ها هم يرفضون طلباتهم.
وزير الخارجية التركي مرود جاويش
الخاصة الاوروبية لورانس
ميلنيكوف قائلا نحاول عمدا ان
تايمز قالت انها البرازيل لكننا
نحن واياكم متابعينا نعلم لمن تم
سلام مع موسكو حتى لو لم ينفع
ذلك، فهل تحاول واشنطن كسب الوقت
لطيفا وان يعطي الانطباع الواهم
بان كييف تريد الدخول في مفاوضات
وقالت الوزارة الصينية على
واشنطن العمل معنا وتجنب سوء
لقاء شخصي بينهما منذ تولي بايدن
منصبه والذي سيوفر فرصة لتوضيح
قال انه يتبعها مع بوتين لاقناعه
دائما حيث قال الرئيس التركي لو
اهم علاقة ثنائية في العالم. لكن
ومع هذا كله فقد حذرت الخارجية
بحسب فاينشيال تايمز البريطانية
لكن هل تجدي استعدادات الجزيرة
بينغ وجها لوجه يوم الاثنين
الرابع عشر من نوفمبر في اول
ومن الحروب الحزبية الى الحرب
التجسسية وسائل اعلام غربية.
الناتو في اوكرانيا حيث يمكن
لضربة من هذا النوع ان توقف
الفهم والتقدير. وخلال هذه
المحادثات الصينية الامريكية
القضائية الدولة التي اتصل بها
المهندس لكن صحيفة النيويورك
غواصات واسلحة نووية لقوة اجنبية
معادية ولم تحدد السلطات
تسريب المعلومات نعم لقد اجبتم
ان لم تكن روسيا فهي بدون شك
الخطوط الحمراء فعن اي خطوط
تتحدثون يا ترى تعلن وسائل اعلام
ان حزبه خسر مقاعد اقل في مجلس
النواب مما هو في المتوسط لحزب
البنية التحتية العسكرية
والمدنية لاوكرانيا وتترك البلاد
كهرومغناطيسية الهدف منها تدمير
المعدات الدفاعية التي نشرها
الغربية لنار دينيبرو عدم مواجهة
الجيش الاوكراني بالقرب من مدينة
ستسمح للجمهوريين بالتضييق على
جو بايدن خلال العامين المقبلين.
الحكم على مهندس في البحرية
الامريكية مع زوجته بسجن تسعة
رئيس لا يزال في المنصب لكن حتى
الاغلبية الضئيلة في مجلس النواب
وهو من الحزب الديموقراطي انه
مستعد للعمل مع الجمهوريين. وقال
مخاوف اوكرانيا واشنطن لن تمنح
كييف طائرات مسيرة من طراز جراي
والسلوك التوسعي واظهار قدرات
الحلفاء المعززة. وذلك بحسب
ناشيونال انترست كشفت ان امدادات
واشنطن لكييب تواجه معضلتين
الامريكان الموجة الحمراء
العملاقة لم تحدث هكذا صرخ بها
الطائرة واستنساخها وذلك حال
سقطت في ايدي الروس. وكان وزير
بين جمهوري وديمقراطي تتأرجح
خمسون ولاية. فماذا بعد
صحيفة. امريكا تتأرجح. الولايات
المتحدة ما عادت تتسع لكليهما
بايدن والفرحة تملأ وجهه
المتجعد. وبينما توقع الجمهوريون
اقوى دولة في العالم تعيش ما
جعلت كثيرا من الدول تعيشه وما
الشمالي في محاولة استفزازية
لروسيا ليظهر قائد العمليات
التضاريس الوعرة. وليس هذا وحسب
بل انها تساعد على حمل الاشياء
بموجبه رحلات مباشرة لحضور
مباريات كأس العالم في الدولة
الخارجية الاسرائيلية توقع
اتفاقا مع قطر والفيفا يتم
المسيرة في غضون عام واحد ضمن
جهودها لردع اي تهديد صيني وذلك
السياسي الى الاستفاقة المفاجئة
حيث اجرت قوات العمليات الخاصة
مرتقبة لبوتين الى دومبس. فما
الذي يخطط له الرئيس الروسي?
لاعادة تصنيع اسلحتها؟ ام ان
هناك مغزى اخر. ومن التنويم
الامريكية عملية اسقاط تدريبي
لصاروخ بعيد المدى في القطب
ميداني للاحتياجات اللازمة لدعم
الجيش بينما تدفع موسكو ببدلات
بالنسبة لتملك ارض. فرنسيون
يقفون بمطعم وجبات سريعة حدادا
نتنياهو الى السلطة? من نوع اخر
يكشف عنها الرئيس اردوجان الذي
الصينية ان على واشنطن وقف
استخدام القضايا التجارية سلاحا.
تايوان تستغل انشغال بكين وتحاول
بناء سلسلة امداد محلية للطائرات
لاصحاب العيون الضيقة. واشنطن
تطلب ود الصين. ما لم يأت بالقوة
ايجل المتطورة. وبحسب مسؤولين
امريكيين فان سبب رفض واشنطن
يا ترى? ومن خيارات موسكو الى
معضلات الامريكان. صحيفة ذي
يصدر قرارا غير مسبوق بمعاملة
الاميرة نوف بنت مقرن ال سعود
محادثات عسكرية بين الجزائر
وروسيا. اذ استقبل رئيس اركان
الاوكرانية فالمد الاوكراني
يزداد مقابل جزر روسي غامض ويا
دخان الحرب لا يتوقف. بين كر وفر
وشد وجذب. تتواصل الحرب الروسية
الحاجة لرفع كميات انتاج الذخائر
بشكل يفوق طاقاتها. لتظهر
خرسون. استعدنا السيطرة على مائة
وخمسين كيلو مترا مربعا من مساحة
تسريبات امريكية جديدة بان جيك
سوليفان طلب من زينونسكي ان يكون
الفاعل. وتايوان تستعد للحرب في
حين تمد واشنطن يدها لتفاوض
ان يسيطر على مجلس النواب لكن
امنيتهم لم تتحقق. ليعلنها بايدن
نكون استفزازيين دون تصعيد.
نحاول احتواء عدوان الروسي
خطيرتين في صميم الامن القومي
الامريكي تتمثلان في نقص الذخيرة
لدى وزارة الدفاع والصعوبات التي
يواجهها التصنيع عسكري بسبب
قد ياتي باللين والتفاوض. وبعد
ان فشلت امريكا في تهديد بكين.
عشر عاما وواحدا وعشرين عاما على
التوالي لمحاولتهما بيع اسرار
بدون ضوء او حرارة او اتصالات او
حتى وسائل نقل. هنا تضيف سي ان
ارسالها لاوكرانيا هو خوفهم من
سرقة التكنولوجيا الموجودة داخل
الروبوت القتالية الى الحرب في
اوكرانيا. حيث تمنح هذه البدلات
محتمل لتوربيد جديد يعمل بالطاقة
النووية. فاي طريقة سيختار بوتين
خرسون في جنوب اوكرانيا وذلك
تزامنا مع اعلان غامض عن زيارة
ان عن مسؤول امريكي رصدنا
استعداد سفن حربي روسية لاختبار
له من غموض مرعب. هنا رئيس
الادارة العسكرية الاوكرانية في
واسرار الغواصات النووية
الامريكية يتم تسريبها بامان
الجزائر وروسيا تزعج الغرب.
وسياسة غريبة وجديدة لتركيا
سوناك شيئا ويخفي مخاوف لندن
يؤكدها اصدار الرئيس الروسي
الثقيلة. امريكا لاوكرانيا نحن
نعتذر هنا قرار امريكي يزيد
فلاديمير بوتين قرارا لوزارة
المالية من اجل اجراء تقييم
الدفاع الروسي قد امر مسبقا
قواته بالانسحاب من الضفة
مرتديها قوة هائلة ودقة مميتة
وتساعد على الجري السريع في
تتخذها مع روسيا اسرائيل
واردوغان يعلنها بوتين يحترمني.
من رد روسي؟ والموجة الحمراء
تعجز عن ابتلاع السلطة الامريكية
الروسية نعم قالها سوناك في حين
جمدت بلاده اصولا روسية بقيمة
ثمانية عشر مليار جنيه استرليني
وهنا نقصد بريطانيا. فهل يعلم
ليخرج تقرير بريطاني يقول ان
روسيا قد تنفذ ضربة نووية
تجاه الانسحاب الروسي من خرسون
فحفيد جاندي يشتم رائحة الفخاخ
خرسون. بينما اكد رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريش سوناك على الحذر
توزع بدلات خارقة لجنودها واجراء
عسكري امريكي يستفز روسيا. فهل
بكين. فهل سيتم تسليم تايوان دون
قتال? محادثات عسكرية بين
موسكو تعد العدة لضربة صادمة
والانسحاب جزء من الخطة وبوتين
وبيض يصرخ باعلى صوته. فما يجري
في الولايات المتحدة يا سادة
يصدر قراره على الفور فما الذي
يخطط له الروس هذه المرة؟ وموسكو
تعيش